esta es tu última oportunidad si no el
spray de pimienta levantada en los ojos
solo rocía la limpia en mis ojos por
favor
estas imágenes del arresto de una niña
de nueve años ha desatado una nueva ola
de indignación contra los métodos de las
fuerzas del orden en rochester la
policía de esta ciudad hizo públicos el
domingo dos vídeos en los que se ve cómo
los agentes esposan a la niña la rocían
con las mantas después de que intentara
huir
la alcaldesa de rochester ordenó el
lunes la suspensión inmediata de los
agentes implicados
las suspensiones continuarán como mínimo
hasta que concluyan los resultados de la
investigación policial interna lo que
ocurrió el viernes fue sencillamente
horrible y ha indignado con razón a toda
nuestra comunidad según el sub jefe de
policía los agentes respondían a una
llamada por problemas familiares y
fueron informados de que la niña quería
suicidarse y matar a su madre después de
que se publicaran las imágenes el lunes
integrantes del movimiento black la ex
madre marcharon hasta la comisaría
pidiendo la renuncia del presidente del
sindicato
mike máximo huevo y un pequeño adelanto
nuestra próxima parada hacia el
sindicato de la policía mike maceo toma
nota vamos por ti ya puedes empezar a
afirmar tus papeles de dimisión el
incidente tiene preocupantes similitudes
con la muerte de daniel truck un hombre
afroamericano que murió en marzo después
de que la policía de rage esther le
colocará una capucha en la cabeza
mientras sufría una crisis de salud
mental tras la muerte de frei
la alcaldesa despidió al jefe de policía